brothers and sisters has helped me on
this new project to sponsor 50
orphans brothers and sisters in
charlotte it's 600 pounds a year but i
wanted every one of you guys to get
involved by giving even if it's one
pound
please get involved now and shout out
and help us sponsor 50 orphans for an
entire year
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hassana counter download
the qurani app now and have a ramadan
with allah's book like you've never had
before
what's on the side
so basically what we're doing is raising
awareness to what's happening
it's something that you've already seen
in the media um
which is the killing of innocent people
and we don't know why we have those
faces
i don't know why it's basically
disappointing when palestinian kids are
being blown into pieces
and i don't make my face you know if i
saw jewish kids been brought into pizza
but this is what's happening so as you
can see um
there you go there's nothing nobody can
comment it's not outrageous
that's true yeah so say what you'd like
say a word or two and just run away
isn't it that's
that shows great bravery and willingness
to engage
you'll take the whole thing you don't
need to be a muslim to stand up for gaza
are these clashes or genocide
as you know you've got this palestine
and israel thing going on
naturally rather than encouraging people
to be hostile and hungry
yeah you kind of speak you die
there's no issue here if somebody wants
to stop they stop if somebody doesn't
want to stop they don't stop
if we just got a few facts on the screen
we're gonna be here 15 20 minutes
it'll be nice if somebody can dial up
yeah
[Music]
but i think what's gonna happen now is
maybe the police is gonna arrive
and started getting right here so we
just have to run for all safety
we need immediate assistance afghanistan
imagine this will happen to your kids
i'll be the first to stand up
i just want to come forward and have a
conversation
with everyone
i mean why would you cross the road and
not be willing to engage
not all jews are the same fulfill your
filthy blooded creature
how how how how kids palestinian
children